tell me story tell me every detail I  woke up somewhere from a nightmare what  was it about then Thanks then me lots of  care about business  hold up hold up back up you've left  something out are you writing a book  they all lived happily ever after  no they didn't over because for the  first time there's something you don't  know  something nobody told you  you wanted to prophesy this is your  prophecy no man  from hunting faint I'm weary I don't  cover man you on what is that  Gary I know your story  behold the man who pulled sword from  stone I'm not getting drawn into this  mess there's an army of you it's only  one of me  I'll talk I'm happy to talk but there is  no way the I am fighting  you  so what happens now you know happens now  oh you quickly becoming a legend